hey youtubers is Charlie so Marvel is
going to be previewing Avengers 2 age of
Ultron at comic-con I wanted to do video
explaining the vision they also just
screened a bunch of unfinished footage
for an audience in London so I'm going
to do a breakdown of what that was for a
lot of you comic-book readers out there
yes they are changing the origin story
of the vision just like the Ultron
character but hey you know they just
announced they're making Thor female so
it's just another day in the Marvel
Universe hello to any new people if
you're finding me for the first time I
do Marvel videos every week be sure to
subscribe to get everything
lots of awesome Comic Con stuff planned
I'm going to be recording the panel so
I'll talk about that at the end of this
video so let's just start with the
footage they screened then I'll explain
how the movie is going to treat the
vision so it was all unfinished footage
it was just captured that it had been
edited down they showed off the
Hulkbuster armor way bigger than the I
Gore suit we saw an Iron Man 3
it's the customary red and gold colors
though size-wise it's about the same
size as the Hulk in the comics it always
seemed way bigger but Mark Ruffalo's
version of the character is way shrunk
down from angley's version and the
Edward Norton version it's like each
time they do a new Hulk movie the hook
gets a little bit smaller there was also
a bunch of Scarlet Witch Quicksilver
stuff they were seen inside these clear
perspex prison cells
you know like basically clear plastic
cells then we saw some fight scenes
alongside Hawkeye like the images we saw
from the set earlier this year there was
also a little bit of them using their
powers but remember they did not have
special effects on the footage
Quicksilver was running but you know
because no special effects it looked
more like he was jogging and Scarlet
Witch just you know floating blocks the
really cool thing though was they showed
off the Avengers Tower it looks a lot
like the interior of the shield
Helicarrier Bruce Banner and Tony Stark
each have twin labs next to each other
so they can make all of the science then
there's a hangar bay for the quintet
which will be in the movie and all the
Avengers have sleeping quarters so I'm
assuming that everyone besides store you
know all the earth-based superheroes
have homes elsewhere
they'll just be bunking at the Avengers
tower during the course of the movie if
you didn't hear earlier this year
it's been explained that Thor has been
living on earth since the events of dark
world presumably the movie is going to
explain why I know the end of dark world
was a little confusing with the way it
left the characters I know it doesn't
sound like a ton of footage and
everyone's expecting the comic-con
trailer they're going to bring to be an
order of magnitude
cooler with Finnish special effects it
won't be like a full-on trailer but it
will be a promo reel I will be doing a
full breakdown to that and uploading the
panel footage that's happening Saturday
night July 26 I probably won't be able
to upload videos each night to like
super late but I'll be tweeting the
out of the panel's there are a few
movies that Marvel is not taking to
comic-con like guardians of the galaxy
but aside from Avengers 2 the cast of
ant-man is going to be there and Marvel
is going to reveal the complete slate of
phase 3 films so now let's talk about
the vision the character that Paul
Bettany is playing in the movie they're
basically changing the backstory just
like they did with the Ultron character
to fit within the movie canon that
they've already created here's a quick
history lesson the vision was created by
Ultron originally in the comics using
the remains of the original Human Torch
Android I know everyone thinks of Johnny
Storm is the Human Torch but before him
in Android named Jim Hammond used the
mantle during World War 2 to fight
Hitler and the Axis powers that version
of the character was actually one of
Marvel's very first superheroes he's
super old
Ultron reprogrammed him to fight the
Avengers that first happened in the late
1960s
Ultron programmed the vision with the
neural patterns of Wonder Man so that he
could infiltrate the Avengers he also
embedded a fail-safe device in the
vision called a control crystal like an
override switch so the Janet Van Dyne
wasp is actually the person who gave him
his vision name the wasp called him and
an earthly in human vision and thus the
name vision was born so already you see
they're gonna have to make some changes
to his origin story in the movie just
because we don't have the wasp vision
ended up sympathizing with the Avengers
and help them defeat Ultron I feel like
some of the details of the character
everyone knows like he ended up getting
married to Scarlet Witch at one point
eventually that failsafe device that
Ultron embedded in a malfunction and he
went nuts trying to make the world
perfect he fixed the problem but the
military deemed him a huge security
threat and then many many years later
Scarlet Witch lost her mind and did the
whole no more mutants thing setting off
the House of M storyline that was
basically when the vision got torn apart
and thrown in a closet
eventually they brought him back for the
Mighty Avengers storyline and most
recently he's been a big part of
Avengers AI if you remember Mighty
Avengers is actually rumored to be the
inspiration for the story in Avengers 2
so she doll
read that book the interesting thing
about the vision is that he is an
Android but he develops very human
connections to people he even had
romantic relationships with Scarlet
Witch and later with Cassandra Lang
she's actually the daughter of the Scott
Lang ant-man the one that Paul Rudd is
playing in the ant-man movie small world
so regardless of what Avengers 2 does
with the character and you know how the
story plays out the core of the
character will remain you know him
forming very human attachments to the
other Avengers and joining the team
eventually I'm really hoping that he
survives the end of the movie and makes
it into Avengers 3 and some of the
spin-offs too they probably signed Paul
Bettany to some crazy Sam Jackson long
contract for those that don't know
typically a Marvel contract is like a
six picture deal like they can put you
in any six movies they want they just
call you up and say hey you have to be
in this movie Samuel Jackson's contract
had extra movies on top of that because
he had to be in all those extra movies
but the next big question is is what is
Avengers 2 gonna change about the vision
character mostly his origin story the
outcomes going to be the same he'll be
an Avenger eventually the differences I
think he's going to be based on stark
tech created to fight Ultron instead of
created by Ultron to fight the Avengers
there have been a couple things that
confirm this theory mostly that Paul
Bettany was cast as the vision and he's
going to be like full-on Paul Bettany in
the movie like his body will be used it
won't just be his voice the visions
going to be a combination of practical
effects and motion capture just like
Ultron one thing I'm really curious
about though is which characters they
let name him like if it's going to be
Tony Stark or it's going to be some
twist on the original wasp line and
speaking of motion capture did you know
that Andy Serkis has a role in the movie
a motion capture role that is they
haven't revealed who he's playing other
than to say that it's not fan OHS but if
paul bettany is doing the vision and
james spader is doing ultron who could
Andy Serkis be playing my thoughts are
is that Joss Whedon is going to like
secretly tease a character that's going
to be a bigger part of Avengers 3 it's
going to be like a character that we did
not know was going to be in Avengers 2
when Whedon talked about the first
Avengers movie he said that when he was
just doing initial talks to join the
project before they ever shot the film
or did the script he told them that
they'd have to let him use Ultron at
some point so if he was thinking Ultron
that early in the game I'm really
curious to see who he's got in his back
pocket right now
in addition to that super secret part
Andy Serkis is playing he's also a
motion capture consultant for the movie
in general so he helps Mark Ruffalo do
better hulk and he's going to help paul
bettany and james spader do their
characters to josh brolin may do a few
days on the film he's rumored to have a
small cameo in Avengers 2 but when they
cast him in guardians of the galaxy they
had already shot all the Thanos stuff so
he's just doing the voice in that movie
but let me know who do you think that
Andy Serkis is playing in Avengers 2 and
do you care that they're changing a lot
of that characters backstories like
Ultron and the vision I'm a huge Whedon
fan so I totally don't mind whatever he
wants to change I've just learned to
trust him and roll with it
and I'd be totally cool if Andy Serkis
just played all the motion capture
characters I don't know what that movie
would look like so I'll be posting at
least one more Marvel bonus video before
Comic Con starts be sure to subscribe to
get it
I'll try to post it by next Tuesday but
I'll explain the special Marvel giveaway
that I'm going to be doing it's going to
be fun I'm doing a whole bunch of
giveaways that week and don't worry if
you can't go to Comic Con I'll be
uploading a bunch of the panels so
you'll still be able to see a lot of it
right now click here to learn all about
the female Thor and click here to get my
review of the guardians of the galaxy
IMAX footage thank you so much for
watching I'll see you guys tomorrow
high fives
you